bonjour pierre emmanuel thomas de merci
de répondre à notre invitation le projet
européen a donc fêté ses 70 ans hier
dans un contexte particulier on l'a dit
un selon un sondage est là pour les
échos radio classique et l'institut
montaigne sur le 20 % des français
jugent que bruxelles a été à la hauteur
de la crise est ce qu'on peut dire que
le courant n'a virus a mis en lumière
les défaillances de lieux le coronavirus
c'est une crise qui s'ajoute en réalité
à d'autres crises qui se sont accumulées
dans l'union européenne
parce que le le système de l'union
européenne les paradigmes sur lesquels
était basée c'est à dire la la société
ouverte
l'élimination des frontières et le socle
idéologique qui est la défense de la
démocratie libérale et multiculturel
multiculturaliste et défier et ne permet
pas de faire face de manière efficace
aux différentes crises parce que je
rappelle que aujourd'hui nous faisons
face à la crise du corona virus mais il
ya aussi la crise migratoire
la rivalité entre les états membres sur
la finalité de l'union européenne entre
le nord le sud l'est et l'ouest
il ya aussi en matière de relations
extérieures des priorités géopolitiques
différentes entre les états membres
notamment vis-à-vis des etats-unis mais
aussi vis-à-vis de la russie
alors effectivement ce projet européen
initié dans les années 50 est mise en
difficulté parce que la configuration
géopolitique des années 50 est
différente de la configuration
géopolitique actuelle ne sommes plus
dans le contexte de la guerre froide et
donc le projet européen n'est plus
adapté au monde multipolaire aujourd'hui
et cette crise du coronavirus révèle les
faiblesses de ce projet européen alors
ils s'adapter il révèle
et faiblesses vous dites de lieux ce
coronavirus mais quelles sont les
conséquences que l'on peut attendre
justement alors pour pour rappeler un
petit peu parce que le nous avons
célébré hier la déclaration schuman à
l'époque pour lancer le projet européen
il y avait la pression extérieure les
etats-unis poussent et à l'unité de
l'europe pour faire face à l' urss qui
était l'ennemi et l'objectif aussi
c'était de surmonter la rivalité franco
allemande mais l'allemagne était divisée
en deux et et était le perdant de la
deuxième guerre mondiale et donc le
c'était une situation plus plus
favorable et l'objectif était de
fusionner les intérêts et notamment en
mettant en commun le charbon et l'acier
et petit à petit créer des solidarités
de fait entre les états membres
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus d' ennemi
commun donc les états membres ont des
priorités différentes en matière de prix
de géo politique extérieure et ensuite
au niveau interne il ya la monnaie
unique qui est l'élément le plus avancé
mais qui n'a pas résoudre les
différences économiques entre les états
membres et on voit à l'occasion de la
crise du coronavirus qui va qui va créer
une crise économique
la réponse de l'union européenne négocié
par les états membres c'est de mettre un
plan de relance mais les états membres
est un membre ne sont pas d'accord sur
la nature de ce plan de relance parce
que les les pays du nord avec
l'allemagne comme chef de file ne
veulent pas mettre en commun les dettes
parce que les états vont s'endetter et
être garant en dernier ressort des
dettes qui vont s'accumuler parce que
forcément ce sera un transfert financier
du nord vers le sud est il n'y a pas de
sentiment de solidarité comme à
l'intérieur d'une nation alors justement
il ya les hits
dire qu'ils trouvent qui a pas ce
sentiment de solidarité un institut de
sondage révèle que les italiens ne sont
plus que 51 % à vouloir rester dans
l'union européenne soit 22 points de
moins qu'en novembre 2018 comment est-ce
que l'union européenne et les européens
peuvent-ils renouer les liens alors le
ce plan de relance justement est fait
pour en fait gagner du temps comme les
états membres du nord dont l'allemagne
et les pays bas ne veulent pas une
mutualisation des dettes mais les pays
du sud pour se renflouer aimerait un
transfert du nord vers le sud mais ne
l'obtiennent pas en réalité les pays du
nord mettre sur la table accepte une
solidarité de donner des liquidités et
on ne sait pas encore si ce seront des
prêts ou dans quelle mesure mais un gros
paquet de liquidités pour essayer de
relancer la machine économique
mais les vrais problèmes les divisions
internes à l'union européenne seront
repoussés plus tard puisque les états
membres ne sont pas d'accord pour faire
un saut fédéral et donc le scénario le
plus positif c'est pendant une période
les entreprises vont devons limiter les
dégâts
les économies vont limiter les dégâts en
attendant la reprise mais il n'y aura
pas de décision entre soit retourné au
niveau de recréer des états-nations fort
avec des circuits courts économique et
recréer une souveraineté des différents
états nations une réindustrialisation ou
alors un saut fédéral il c'est bien ça
le problème parce que tout le projet
européen depuis les années cinquante a
fait en sorte de créer des solidarités
de fait de créer des interdépendances
économiques pour transférer des
compétences au niveau européen mais on
voit bien que le face aux crises ce
n'est pas l'union européenne qui en
première ligne qui peut prendre des
décisions souveraines
ce sont les états qui sont en première
ligne pour le codeur à virus mais aussi
la crise migratoire c'est la grèce qui
stoppe
les les migrants qui pousse à la
frontière merci merci pierre manuel
thomann ces mots de la fin merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le fondateur d'euro continent